coup de coeur du ciné cette semaine
c'est le très beau film neruda de pas me
wade qui sort d'ailleurs aussi un
nouveau film si les astres est
prolifique qui s'appelle jacky qui sort
je crois aujourd'hui donc c'est
l'histoire de pavlov a c'est l'histoire
d'une partie de la vie de pablo neruda
ça se passe en 1948 au chili et ses deux
magnifiques magnifiquement interprété
par louis cne co qui est un vecteur que
je ne connaissais pas qui joue le rôle
de neruda
alors on découvre quoi c'est le moment
où les roues d'ardon pleine guerre
froide se fait traquer par le pouvoir en
place au chili et on découvre cette
aventure puisque son étude avec un
personnage bourré de fantaisie
moi je ne sais pas du tout pas de blé
goude a été un personnage haut en
couleur comme ça et donc c'est la traque
d'un inspecteur neruda va laisser des
traces va jouer en fait avec cet
inspecteur et ça se termine pas très
bien pour l'un des deux personnages mais
je vous en dis pas plus mais je vous
encourage vraiment à venir voir ce très
beau film en version originale aussi 17
temps
montanier
[Musique]